October 19 infection rates have been
falling in Europe the pandemic is
actually escalating in Latin America
particularly in Brazil which has become
the world's third worst hit country with
more than 250,000 confirmed cases
despite limited testing and more than
1000 deaths in the past 24 hours well
joining me now from Sao Paulo in Brazil
is NBC's chief global correspondent bill
Neely good to talk to bill well first of
all 1000 deaths reported in a single day
yesterday that's a record figure for
Brazil and they've had a lot of very bad
days here corona virus is now spreading
faster in brazil than anywhere on earth
and these are from the official figures
no testing here is minimal it's among
the worst testing rates in the world so
many people and I was speaking to a
doctor at a big Hospital this morning
many people believe that the the real
rate is far far higher than that in fact
the doctor I was speaking to this
morning said 15 times higher than the
official figures so there is a huge
crisis here and the result is that for
example the mayor of San Paolo says that
the health system here in this city of
more than 20 million people could
collapse within two weeks and I was at a
hospital this morning where there is a
95 to 100 percent occupancy rate in ICU
in other words it is technically
completely full they have health staff
just as in the UK and the u.s. who are
dying morale is desperately low so yes
Dermott there is a a huge medical crisis
here but there's a political crisis too
because just like in the u.s. brazil has
a president who is not quite a climate
denier but he's not far offered he
doesn't believe in a lockdown he doesn't
believe in social distancing and I think
the chaos at the height of government is
just adding to the crisis here
and does he share president Trump's
enthusiasm for this unproven treatment
hydroxychloroquine
yes Alan teach us this morning the
president and the government approved
hydroxychloroquine and chloroquine in
fact the president Bolton ro says he
keeps a box of it for his 93 year old
mother well the doctor that I spoke to
this morning he's an infectious disease
specialist says that as far as most
doctors in Brazil are concerned there's
absolutely no evidence that this is
either helpful in preventing the disease
or does anything whatsoever
when you've got the disease and this
doctor actually had coronavirus for the
best part of a month so you know Bolton
ro was an outlier there's no question
he's an anti-establishment figure when
he was asked about the record death toll
in Brazil he said so what what do you
want me to do about it he's against the
lockdown he's against social distancing
he had a rally at the weekend in which
he took photographs right beside his
supporters he hugged them he did wear a
mask which is very very unusual for him
because normally he doesn't bother and
just like President Trump in the US he
says Brazilians should get back to work
now I'm just looking out on the streets
right now German and there's quite a lot
of traffic it's not at normal levels but
Brazilians are caught between obeying
what their governors say which is stay
at home and what the president says
which is just get out there I was
speaking to the governor of são Paulo
last night and he told me there are two
viruses in Brazil the corona virus and
the Bolton ro virus and he says it's
almost criminal what the president is
doing sending out these messages so we
haven't yet reached the peak here
Dermott that will come in the next two
weeks and brazil well on course to be
not the third worst but the second worst
country in the world for coronavirus
pili lee in Shambala thank you